Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There was a land of cavaliers and cotton fields called the Old South. Here in this pretty world, gallantry took its last bow. Here was the last ever to be seen of knights and their ladies fair, of master and of slave. Look for it only in books, for it is no more than a dream remembered, a civilization gone with the wind. So that, Tom Holland, is the opening text of the single most
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列内容并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。曾经有一片充满骑士和棉田的土地，被称为“旧南方”。在这个美好的世界里，骑士精神最后一次鞠躬谢幕。这里是最后一次见到骑士与淑女、主人与奴隶的地方。只能在书中寻找它，因为它不过是一个被铭记的梦，一个随风而逝的文明。汤姆·霍兰德，这就是史上最
successful motion picture ever made. Gone with the Wind, released in December 1939, premiered in Atlanta, Georgia, and went on to sell so many admissions tickets that I think one in every two people in the United States and Canada saw it, and pretty much one in every two people in Britain when it ran during the Blitz a year later. So are you a big Gone With The Wind fan, Tom? I've only seen it once, I'm going to be honest. And that was a long time ago. And all I really remember is Scarlett O'Hara going, fiddle-de-dee.
成功的电影的开场白。《乱世佳人》于1939年12月上映，在佐治亚州亚特兰大首映，随后售出的电影票数量之多，以至于我认为美国和加拿大的每两个人中就有一个看过它，而一年后当它在伦敦大轰炸期间上映时，英国几乎每两个人中也有一人看过。那么，汤姆，你是《乱世佳人》的忠实粉丝吗？老实说，我只看过一次。那是很久以前的事了。我唯一记得的就是斯嘉丽·奥哈拉说：“讨厌（fiddle-de-dee）。”
It's pretty much the limit. You didn't model yourself on Rhett Butler? I see you as very Rhett Butler. No, I was kind of much more an Ashley, kind of faintly wet, but sinister. Foppish. Foppish, but sinister. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I mean,
这差不多就是极限了。你没有以瑞德·巴特勒为榜样吗？我觉得你很像瑞德·巴特勒。不，我更像阿什利，有点软弱，但又阴险。娘娘腔。娘娘腔，但又阴险。是的。是的。是的。但我的意思是，
I think it's, Gone with the Wind is obviously, I suppose, with Uncle Tom's Cabin, they're kind of two great literary bookends that surround the history of the Civil War in America and its aftermath. And we've done four episodes so far
我认为，《乱世佳人》显然，我想，它与《汤姆叔叔的小屋》一起，构成了美国内战及其后果历史的两大文学基石。到目前为止，我们已经制作了四集
on the Civil War. And in the last episode, we looked at how it's seen today. So all the kind of enormous contemporary resonances and ramifications that it has. But essentially, we left a big gap. So what happened, basically, from when the Civil War ended up to the present day? And in a way, Gone with the Wind is the kind of the perfect way into looking at that question i think uh and dominic do you know i'm not the only person who thinks that no you're not so someone else who thinks that uh there was suspended book um which is has has just come out i think by the
关于内战的节目。在上一集中，我们探讨了它在今天是如何被看待的。也就是它所具有的巨大的当代共鸣和影响。但本质上，我们留下了一个巨大的空白。那么，从内战结束到今天，到底发生了什么？在某种程度上，我认为《乱世佳人》是审视这个问题的完美切入点。多米尼克，你知道吗，我不是唯一一个这么想的人。不，你不是。还有其他人也这么想，有一本刚出版的书，我想在我们录制这期节目时，
time we record we this is released that's right isn't it tom that is right and when we put um when so when we advertised on twitter asking for for questions we got a reply from count gabriel thursday is this related to sarah churchill's new book actually he said sarah churchill's new book but sarah churchill's new book the wrath to come and do you know dominic it is it is we've got sarah with us hello sarah welcome welcome to the rest is history so your new book, The Wrath to Come, Gone with the Wind and the Lies America Tells. I mean, the subtitle is giving a few clues as to your perspective on this. I decided not to pull any punches. So before we get into the lies that America tells, could we just talk about Gone with the Wind itself? Because I mentioned to Katie, my daughter, who will actually be coming on our next episode to talk
它应该已经发布了，对吧，汤姆？没错。当我们通过推特征集问题时，我们收到了加布里埃尔·瑟斯戴伯爵的回复，问这是否与萨拉·丘吉尔的新书有关。实际上，他说的是萨拉·丘吉尔的新书，但萨拉·丘吉尔的新书《即将来临的愤怒》（The Wrath to Come）——多米尼克，你知道吗，萨拉就在我们身边。你好，萨拉，欢迎来到《历史的余味》。所以你的新书《即将来临的愤怒：〈乱世佳人〉与美国所说的谎言》。我的意思是，副标题已经透露了你对此的观点。我决定不留余地。那么，在我们深入探讨美国所说的谎言之前，我们能先谈谈《乱世佳人》本身吗？因为我告诉了我的女儿凯蒂，她实际上会参加我们的下一集节目来谈论
about Love Island, which is very, very different, very different field of study. And I asked her, had she heard of Gone with the Wind? And she hadn't really. It meant very, very little to her. She'd never seen the film, certainly never read the book. So for people who may not be familiar with it, could you just give us a sense of how colossal a publishing and then a cinematic phenomenon it was is? Yeah, absolutely. And I'll say that that size of its impact is in a sense still registered by the fact that even though your daughter has never seen it or read it, she still has faintly heard of it. So we can flip it on its head and say, it's still out there. People are aware of it, even if only, you know, indirectly and ambiently, but, and that is still the outward reverberations of a century of, as you say, colossal impact. So when it, the novel was published in 1936 and it became an instant word of mouth phenomenon. It didn't have a massive
《恋爱岛》（Love Island），那是一个非常、非常不同的研究领域。我问她是否听说过《乱世佳人》，她其实并没有。这对她来说意义不大。她从未看过这部电影，当然也从未读过这本书。所以，对于那些可能不熟悉它的人，你能给我们讲讲它曾经是多么巨大的出版和电影现象吗？是的，绝对可以。而且我要说，它影响的规模在某种意义上仍然存在，因为尽管你女儿从未看过或读过它，但她还是隐约听说过。所以我们可以反过来说，它依然存在。人们即使只是间接和模糊地了解它，它依然存在，这就是一个世纪以来，正如你所说的，巨大影响力的外在回响。所以，当这部小说在1936年出版时，它立刻成为了口碑现象。它并没有像我们现在习惯的那样，背后有大规模的
publicity campaign behind it in some of the ways that we're now accustomed to. It was a genuine popular hit and it instantly became the book that everybody was reading and everybody was talking about in the United States. So it was written by a woman called Margaret Mitchell. And you said Gone with the Wind is a good way into bridging the gap, but so is Margaret Mitchell, because Margaret Mitchell was born in 1900, and she died in 1949. So her life perfectly spans the first half of the 20th century, and she helps us also cover some of these key milestones in American history that bridge the Civil War until now. She was born in Atlanta, and the famous character of Scarlett O'Hara, if anybody has heard of Gone with the Wind,
宣传活动。它是一个真正的流行热点，并立即成为美国每个人都在阅读和谈论的书。它是由一位名叫玛格丽特·米切尔的女性撰写的。你说《乱世佳人》是弥合差距的好方法，但玛格丽特·米切尔也是，因为她出生于1900年，死于1949年。所以她的一生完美地跨越了20世纪的上半叶，她也帮助我们涵盖了美国历史上一些连接内战至今的关键里程碑。她出生在亚特兰大，而著名的角色斯嘉丽·奥哈拉，如果有人听说过《乱世佳人》，
they've probably heard of Scarlett O'Hara, the novel's heroine. And Margaret Mitchell based Scarlett O'Hara on her own grandmother, who was born into a slaveholding plantation just outside of Atlanta and bitterly resented the loss of her power, her property, including her human property,
他们可能就听说过斯嘉丽·奥哈拉，这部小说的女主角。玛格丽特·米切尔以她自己的祖母为原型塑造了斯嘉丽·奥哈拉，她的祖母出生在亚特兰大郊外的一个蓄奴种植园，并对失去权力、财产，包括她的人口财产，感到极其愤恨，
for the rest of her life, and raised her granddaughter with these stories of the grandeur of the old South of life before the Yankees came and ruined everything for the white slaveholders. And Margaret Mitchell grew up on these legends, and Gone with the Wind is, in one sense, a kind of compendium of these legends. But it's also important to say that from Margaret Mitchell's point of view, she thought she was doing something more realistic. And I'm sure we'll get into that at various points. So in her mind, she was telling a more realistic account of the Civil War years in a popular novel. The novel became a massive bestseller in the United States, and then it exported very, very quickly. And it went across Europe as fascism was on the rise.
余生都在向孙女讲述旧南方在北方佬到来并毁掉白人奴隶主的一切之前的那种辉煌。玛格丽特·米切尔在这些传说中长大，《乱世佳人》在某种意义上就是这些传说的大全。但同样重要的是要说，从玛格丽特·米切尔的角度来看，她认为自己在做一些更现实的事情。我相信我们会在不同阶段讨论这一点。所以在她看来，她在一部流行小说中讲述了内战时期更真实的叙述。这部小说在美国成为了巨大的畅销书，然后很快就出口到了国外。随着法西斯主义的兴起，它传遍了欧洲。
And in fact, not only was it loved by people who were starting to see incursions by Hitler and Mussolini, but it was also loved reportedly by, and indeed documentedly, by many Nazis as well. Eventually the Nazis banned it. So I mean, it was popular everywhere is my point as it started to spread. And then the rights to the novel were instantly acquired by the legendary producer, David Selznick, who understood publicity very, very well. And he began a campaign to find the perfect Scarlett O'Hara. It was called The Search for Scarlett. This became a massive publicity campaign that filled papers and film magazines and the equivalent of social media at the time. And everybody wanted to be Scarlett. And so the idea was that millions could try out
事实上，它不仅受到那些开始看到希特勒和墨索里尼入侵的人们的喜爱，据报道，甚至有记录显示，许多纳粹分子也喜爱它。最终纳粹禁了它。所以我的意思是，它在各地都很受欢迎。然后这部小说的版权立即被传奇制片人大卫·塞尔兹尼克买下，他非常了解宣传。他发起了一场寻找完美斯嘉丽·奥哈拉的运动。这被称为“寻找斯嘉丽”。这变成了一场巨大的宣传活动，充斥着报纸、电影杂志和当时相当于社交媒体的东西。每个人都想成为斯嘉丽。所以当时的想法是，数百万人可以尝试
across the country and maybe he would find an unknown. And so, you know, you could be an amateur actress and still try to be Scarlett O'Hara. And he told all of these publicity stories about how he was going to cast the story and who would be the perfect stars of this, you know, incredibly popular novel. So that by the time the film was released at the end of 1939, it was backed by this three-year relentless publicity campaign. And it became an absolutely smash hit phenomenon. They said it was the greatest motion picture ever made, the greatest Hollywood movie. And it should be said, 1939 remains the classic year of Hollywood cinema, a year of greats like The Wizard of Oz and many other classic movies. But Gone with the
在全国范围内选角，也许他能找到一个新人。所以，你知道，你可以是一个业余演员，仍然可以尝试成为斯嘉丽·奥哈拉。他讲述了所有关于他将如何选角以及谁将成为这部极其流行的小说的完美明星的宣传故事。因此，当这部电影在1939年底上映时，它得到了这场为期三年的无情宣传活动的支持。它成为了一个绝对的轰动现象。他们说这是有史以来最伟大的电影，最伟大的好莱坞电影。而且应该说，1939年仍然是好莱坞电影的经典之年，是《绿野仙踪》等许多经典电影的伟大年份。但《乱世佳人》
Wind beat them all. And it was the movie that everybody wanted to see. And again, it exported very quickly through Europe, through war-torn Europe. And as Dominic mentioned, at the top was incredibly popular during the Blitz, for example. People were queuing up in Leicester Square as bombs burned from the overnight bombings, or fires burned, I mean. So one of the iconic scenes in the film
击败了它们所有人。它是每个人都想看的电影。同样，它很快通过欧洲，通过饱受战争蹂躏的欧洲出口。正如多米尼克提到的，在开头，它在伦敦大轰炸期间非常受欢迎。例如，当炸弹在夜间轰炸中燃烧，或者火光冲天时，人们在莱斯特广场排队。所以电影中标志性的场景之一
is when Atlanta gets burnt by General Sherman. Yeah, we talked about that in that Civil War narrative, didn't we? Sherman's march to the sea and the scorched earth policy. And I learned from your book that Margaret Mitchell's grandmother had lived through the burning of Atlanta. So presumably that is something that is on the minds of people in the blitz they're kind of they're going in and they're seeing uh atlanta burn and then they're coming out and they're seeing you know london the london skyline lit up with fire and one of the kind of the great theme in gone with the wind is i mean scarlet ahara is a is a i mean she's a piece of work in a way isn't she i mean she's what you would call heroin she's what you would call a baggage yeah she's
是亚特兰大被谢尔曼将军烧毁的时候。是的，我们在内战叙事中谈过那个，不是吗？谢尔曼的向海进军和焦土政策。我从你的书中了解到，玛格丽特·米切尔的祖母亲身经历了亚特兰大的焚烧。所以大概这就是伦敦大轰炸期间人们脑海中的事情，他们进去看亚特兰大燃烧，然后出来看到伦敦的天际线被火光照亮。而《乱世佳人》中的一个伟大主题是，我的意思是，斯嘉丽·奥哈拉是一个，我的意思是，她是个狠角色，不是吗？我的意思是，你会称她为女主角，你会称她为“麻烦精”。是的，她确实是
indeed a baggage she's very 18th century baggage. But her kind of great life's mission is to get back her family plantation, which is called Tara, which was this kind of, it's where the land of cavaliers and cotton fields and all that kind of stuff with which it opens. And then it gets destroyed in the Civil War. And her life's mission is to get it back and get her life back on an even keel. So presumably, this is the message that people during war-torn Europe are picking up on. It's this idea that things will get back to normal. I just have to dig deep and I will be able to get it back. It's a story about resilience. And it's a story about survivalism, fundamentally on its most
一个麻烦精，非常18世纪的麻烦精。但她伟大的生活使命是夺回她的家庭种植园，也就是塔拉庄园，那是那种“充满骑士和棉田的土地”以及所有开篇提到的东西。然后它在内战中被摧毁了。她的人生使命是夺回它，让她的生活重回正轨。所以大概，这就是饱受战争蹂躏的欧洲人们所领悟到的信息。这是一种生活会恢复正常的感觉。我只需要深入挖掘，我就能夺回它。这是一个关于韧性的故事。从最
emotional level. And that's what people respond to. And it's worth, before we skip to war-torn Europe, remembering that it hits America in the middle of the Great Depression. So Americans who are struggling, people on drought-stricken farms who are struggling themselves with famine, Scarlet has to overcome hunger. She has to, yeah, and she overcomes the blight of her farm. And so first you have the blight of the Great Depression, and then you have the blight of the Great Depression, and then you have the blight of the Second World War. And in both of these two historical cataclysms, this story about human endurance and survival and sheer defiance, determination, Scarlet is determined no matter what. And as you said, what makes her a baggage is that she's
情感层面来看，这是一个关于生存主义的故事。这就是人们所回应的。值得一提的是，在我们跳到饱受战争蹂躏的欧洲之前，要记住它在经济大萧条时期冲击了美国。所以那些正在挣扎的美国人，在干旱农场里正与饥荒作斗争的人们，斯嘉丽必须克服饥饿。她必须，是的，她克服了农场的枯萎病。所以首先你有经济大萧条的枯萎，然后你有第二次世界大战的枯萎。在这两次历史性的大灾难中，这个关于人类耐力、生存和纯粹反抗、决心的故事，斯嘉丽无论如何都下定决心。正如你所说，让她成为“麻烦精”的是她
totally unscrupulous, it. And she will literally do anything. So, you know, at one point she considers becoming Rhett Butler's mistress. If that's what it's going to take, that's what she'll, that's what she'll do. She, she will sell herself in marriage. She does sell herself in marriage. She's perfectly happy, not happy, but she's prepared to do whatever it takes. And that's what people have always responded to with Scarlett O'Hara. And the other thing I think that's important to say at the top in terms of its popularity, Scarlett O'Hara, and I talk about this at some length in the book, is really the first American every woman, the first popular character who everybody identifies with, but who's female.
完全不择手段。她真的会做任何事。所以，你知道，在某一时刻，她考虑成为瑞德·巴特勒的情妇。如果这是必须的，她就会去做。她会把自己卖给婚姻。她确实把自己卖给了婚姻。她非常乐意，不，不是乐意，但她准备好做任何必要的事情。这就是人们一直对斯嘉丽·奥哈拉所回应的。我认为在受欢迎程度方面，另一件重要的事情是，斯嘉丽·奥哈拉，我在书中详细讨论过，确实是第一个美国“每一个女性”，第一个每个人都认同的流行角色，但她是女性。
And that's for women, that's incredibly important. And so for a lot of women, she became this very interesting feminist figure because she's powerful. And as we said, she's defiant, but she's also deeply problematic. And she's a horrible person in a lot of ways. But that makes her human. And that again, makes her relatable.
这对女性来说非常重要。所以对很多女性来说，她成为了一个非常有趣的女性主义人物，因为她很强大。正如我们所说，她很反叛，但她也存在严重的问题。她在很多方面都是一个可怕的人。但这让她变得人性化。这再次让她变得可亲。
And so she's an important landmark in popular culture for women as well. So we had a comment from Sarah Jones who says, I think it's an important film, because it's a rare film from the female gaze. It's a war film with not a single battle scene. It's a woman's experience of war. And that's actually pretty rare. So yeah, it's true. And again, this was a way that the again, the story was received first the novel and then the film very strongly in the among the first readers. Its early reception was that it was an anti-war novel. And that was really important in that what you see is the cost of war for civilians. It's that you
所以她也是女性流行文化中的一个重要里程碑。我们收到了萨拉·琼斯的评论，她说：“我认为这是一部重要的电影，因为它是一部罕见的从女性视角出发的电影。这是一部没有战斗场景的战争片。这是女性对战争的体验。这实际上非常罕见。”所以是的，这是真的。同样，这也是故事最初被接收的方式，首先是小说，然后是电影，在第一批读者中反响非常强烈。它早期的反响是它是一部反战小说。这非常重要，因为你看到的是平民在战争中的代价。这就是你
don't see, it's a civil war novel with no battles. You don't see any battles. Nobody goes to the battle. You just see the casualties. You see the casualties. It's kind of famous shot, isn't it, which is actually on the cover of your book. Yeah. Where is it, Scarlett has gone to try and get someone to help with with a pregnancy with a birth with a labor yeah exactly labor and the camera pulls back and you see this kind of vast field full of of carnage so she goes to the train depot to try to find the doctor and the doctor is tending the war wounded and dying and and scarlet is being very selfish and saying that she has to help her friend melanie her sister-in-law um give birth and the doctor is being very selfish and saying that she has to help her friend, Melanie, her sister-in-law, give birth.
看不到的，这是一部没有战斗的内战小说。你看不到任何战斗。没有人去战斗。你只看到伤亡。你看到伤亡。这是一个著名的镜头，不是吗？实际上就在你书的封面上。是的。在哪里，斯嘉丽去试图找人帮忙处理怀孕、分娩、阵痛。是的，正是阵痛。镜头拉远，你看到这片广阔的土地上充满了杀戮。所以她去火车站试图找医生，医生正在照顾战争中的伤员和垂死者，而斯嘉丽非常自私，说她必须帮助她的朋友梅兰妮，也就是她的小姑子，分娩。医生非常自私，说她必须帮助她的朋友梅兰妮，也就是她的小姑子，分娩。
And the doctor is like, what are you talking about? I've got thousands of dying soldiers. You're going to have to handle the pregnancy on your own. And then, as you say, the camera pans back to these scores and scores and scores of wounded and dying soldiers to give a sense of the scale of the carnage. And Sarah, just one last thing.
医生说，你在说什么？我有成千上万垂死的士兵。你得自己处理怀孕的事。然后，正如你所说，镜头平移回到这些成群结队的受伤和垂死的士兵身上，以展现杀戮的规模。萨拉，最后一件事。
You mentioned Rhett Butler Butler played by Clark Gable in the film probably the most famous line maybe in the whole of of Hollywood frankly my dear I don't give a damn with which which it ends it's still the most it's still on on you know things like the American Film Institute's list of most famous movie quotes that is still the most famous movie quote to this day frankly my dear I don't give a damn. So just before we move on from what Gone with the Wind and the plot and everything, could you just tell us briefly about Scarlett O'Hara and men and what her, because that's also, I mean, the key part of the plot, isn't it? And there are two in particular, there's the guy who she thinks she's in love with, and then there's the guy who she discovers actually all
你提到了瑞德·巴特勒，由克拉克·盖博在电影中扮演，这可能是好莱坞历史上最著名的一句台词，“坦白说，亲爱的，我一点也不在乎（Frankly, my dear, I don't give a damn）”，电影以此结尾。它仍然是，它仍然在，你知道，美国电影学会最著名电影台词名单上，这仍然是迄今为止最著名的电影台词。所以，在我们离开《乱世佳人》的情节和一切之前，你能简要告诉我们关于斯嘉丽·奥哈拉和男人们的事吗？因为那也是，我的意思是，情节的关键部分，不是吗？特别是有两个，一个是她认为自己爱上的男人，另一个是她发现其实一直以来
along she was in love with. Yeah. So Scarlett is a kind of heroine chasing the wrong hero for most of the story. So she thinks that she loves Ashley. Every reader of the novel and the audience of the film can see instantly that Ashley is not the right man for her. And that Rhett Butler, who is her twin in kind of every way, they're complete kindred spirits. They're both rogues and renegades and they're scoundrels, but they're sort of lovable rogues and, and they're, they're made for each other. And, and Rhett knows that he's older and wiser and very sexy. And so he's the kind of masterful man and Scarlet is beautiful, but she doesn't, but she doesn't have any emotional self-knowledge and, and to say the least. And so the, the story is, you know, it spans, I think I should know this, but it spans 13 years. And she, and as I
她都爱着的男人。是的。所以斯嘉丽是一个在故事大部分时间里追逐错误英雄的女主角。她认为她爱阿什利。小说的每一位读者和电影的观众都能立刻看出阿什利不是适合她的男人。而瑞德·巴特勒，在某种程度上是她的双胞胎，他们是完全志同道合的灵魂。他们都是流氓、叛徒和无赖，但他们是那种可爱的流氓，他们是天造地设的一对。瑞德知道他更年长、更聪明，而且非常性感。所以他是那种掌控全局的男人，而斯嘉丽很漂亮，但她没有任何情感上的自我认知，至少可以这么说。所以，故事是，你知道，它跨越了，我想我应该知道这个，但它跨越了13年。正如我
say, at one point in my book, you know, she literally learns nothing except that she loved the wrong man. And it takes her over a decade to figure that out. So Ashley, as you said at the beginning, Tom is this kind of, he's, you called him wet. He is, he's nostalgic. He represents the old South and he represents this old way of life. And he's idealistic and a bit naive and he reads books and he's ineffective, but he's handsome. And so Scarlet kind of falls for him as a young girl
在书中提到的，你知道，她真的什么都没学到，除了她爱错了人。她花了一年多的时间才弄明白这一点。所以阿什利，正如你开头所说的，汤姆，他是那种，你称他为“软弱”。他是，他是怀旧的。他代表了旧南方，代表了这种旧的生活方式。他理想主义，有点天真，他读书，他效率低下，但他很英俊。所以斯嘉丽作为一个年轻女孩爱上了他，
and then never changes her mind until the very end. Rhett is this dashing, as I say, he's this rogue who comes in and he's the black sheep of his old aristocratic family. And he recognizes that Scarlet is a kindred spirit, but she's too pig-headed to see it. And so he spends most of the story trying to convince her that he's right for her, but he won't. He's too proud, of course, to let his real feelings show. And one of the things that's so famous about Gone with the Wind as a story is that as a romance, it's a very rare thing in that it's not star-crossed. They don't die, but they don't
直到最后都没有改变主意。瑞德是那种潇洒的，正如我所说，他是那种闯入的流氓，是他古老贵族家庭中的害群之马。他认识到斯嘉丽是志同道合的灵魂，但她太固执了，看不出来。所以他花了大半个故事试图说服她他是适合她的，但他不会。他太骄傲了，当然，不愿让真实的感情流露。关于《乱世佳人》作为一个故事最著名的一点是，作为一部浪漫片，它非常罕见，因为它不是那种“苦命鸳鸯”。他们没有死，但他们也没有
reconcile either. Rhett walks out on her. And that's when he says, frankly, my dear, I don't give a damn. It's the answer to her question. If you leave me, where shall I go? What shall I do? And he says, I don't care. And walks out the door. And that's the end of the story. And so it's a very famous ending for romance. So the hero walks out and says, up yours. So, Sarah, the subtitle of your book is The Lies America Tells. And one way to maybe start getting towards that part of the story is to talk about the film's premiere. So it premieres in Atlanta, Georgia.
和解。瑞德离开了她。那就是他说“坦白说，亲爱的，我一点也不在乎”的时候。这是对她问题的回答。如果你离开我，我该去哪里？我该怎么办？他说，我不在乎。然后走出了门。这就是故事的结局。所以对于浪漫片来说，这是一个非常著名的结局。英雄走开了，说“去你的”。所以，萨拉，你书的副标题是“美国所说的谎言”。开始触及故事那一部分的一个方法，也许是谈谈电影的首映式。它在佐治亚州亚特兰大首映。
There are 300,000 people, I think, on the streets at this huge procession. People dress up, don't they, in costume from the Civil War era. It's a state holiday. It's a huge moment for the city of Atlanta, which is this kind of booming New South City, for Georgia, for the old Confederacy. And it seems like you could say a lovely moment of reconciliation
我想街上有30万人参加了这场盛大的游行。人们打扮起来，不是吗？穿着内战时期的服装。这是一个州假日。这对亚特兰大这座“新南方”蓬勃发展的城市，对佐治亚州，对旧邦联来说，是一个巨大的时刻。这看起来像是一个可爱的和解时刻
between North and South. But obviously there are all kinds of shadows. A great example of that is the fact that one of the stars, Hattie McDaniel, is not welcome at the premiere. None of the black cast was welcome at the premiere. So she's playing Mammy, who is the maid at Tara. So the housekeeper and Scarlett's nurse and the most important black character in the film.
在北方和南方之间。但显然有各种各样的阴影。一个很好的例子是，主演之一海蒂·麦克丹尼尔在首映式上并不受欢迎。黑人演员都没有受到首映式的欢迎。所以她扮演的是“妈咪”，也就是塔拉庄园的女仆。也就是管家和斯嘉丽的护士，也是电影中最重要的黑人角色。
Hattie McDaniel would, of course, go on to become the first African-American actor to win an Academy Award for her performance in Gone with the Wind. And exactly. So people need to remember that when the movie came out, segregation was still in force in Atlanta. The black cast was not invited to the premiere. So you have pictures of this all white audience.
海蒂·麦克丹尼尔当然会成为第一位因在《乱世佳人》中的表演而获得奥斯卡奖的非裔美国演员。没错。所以人们需要记住，当电影上映时，亚特兰大仍然实行种族隔离。黑人演员没有被邀请参加首映式。所以你有这些全白人观众的照片。
And when, you know, Dominic, you say that they were dressing up in Civil War costume. Well, it was cosplay, but it was cosplay as slave owners. So they weren't dressing up as slaves. They were dressing up as slave holders. And they were white women and dressing up as Southern bells in the big hoop skirts and men dressed up in 19th century clothing. But that was so that you could role play that the fantasy was that you still owned a plantation with hundreds of African-American slaves. And so just beyond those happy photographs of white Hollywood stars and white audiences are black picket lines,
当你，你知道，多米尼克，你说他们穿着内战服装。好吧，那是角色扮演，但那是扮演奴隶主。所以他们不是在扮演奴隶。他们是在扮演奴隶主。他们是白人女性，穿着大裙撑的南方淑女服装，男人们穿着19世纪的服装。但那是为了让你能角色扮演，幻想是你仍然拥有一个拥有数百名非裔美国奴隶的种植园。所以，在那些白人好莱坞明星和白人观众的快乐照片之外，是黑人的纠察线，
African-Americans picketing this because it was segregated, because they said this, rightly, they said this is romanticizing slavery. This is romanticizing racial violence. And it's glorifying what still exists as racial inequality and segregation at the time. And so what you have is a Black cast and a white culture that's insisting and a story that says that slavery wasn't bad for America. That's basically the insistence here is that it's all
非裔美国人抗议这一点，因为它是种族隔离的，因为他们说，他们说得对，这是在浪漫化奴隶制。这是在浪漫化种族暴力。它美化了当时仍然存在的种族不平等和种族隔离。所以你拥有的是黑人演员和坚持这种叙事的白人文化，故事说奴隶制对美国来说并不坏。这基本上是这里的坚持，即一切都
over. It's all fine. We can move on and we can just tell this happy story about what slavery was like. And so Black people are literally being told that slavery inflicted no costs on American culture at the same moment that Black people are being excluded from attending a film in which they feature and in which some, as I say, some of these actors um you know uh were going to give award winning performances and when had him and it's important to say this wasn't just in the south so when hattie mcdaniel um won that award she did so at a segregated um ceremony um oscar ceremony from which she had originally been barred from attending that as well and david selznick the
结束了。一切都很好。我们可以继续前进，我们可以讲述这个关于奴隶制是什么样子的快乐故事。所以黑人实际上被告知，奴隶制没有给美国文化带来任何代价，就在同一时刻，黑人被排除在参加一部他们参与其中的电影之外，而正如我所说，其中一些演员，你知道，要给出获奖的表演。当海蒂·麦克丹尼尔，而且重要的是要说，这不仅仅是在南方。所以当海蒂·麦克丹尼尔赢得那个奖项时，她是在一个种族隔离的仪式上，奥斯卡颁奖典礼，她最初也被禁止参加。大卫·塞尔兹尼克，
producer had to pull strings to get her invited to the Coconut Grove where the ceremony was held, because it was segregated too, and that was in Los Angeles. A really naive question. I thought segregation happened in the South. No, it was across the United States. So it was known as the color bar, and exactly, and people think it was only in the South. It was at its worst in the South, but it happened across the country. I always give the example of the famous Cotton Club in Harlem in the 1920s, which many people will have heard of. And people think of it as this mixed race speakeasy. It was whites only customers in Harlem in the 1920s. You had black entertainers and black serving people, you know, staff, but the customers were white only. And that was true across the United States. So the color bar, it wasn't as rigid in the North.
制片人不得不动用关系让她被邀请到举行仪式的椰子林，因为它也是种族隔离的，而且那是在洛杉矶。一个非常天真的问题。我以为种族隔离只发生在南方。不，它遍布整个美国。所以它被称为“肤色限制（color bar）”，没错，人们认为它只在南方。它在南方最严重，但它发生在全国各地。我总是举20世纪20年代哈莱姆区著名的棉花俱乐部为例，很多人都听说过。人们认为它是一个多种族的地下酒吧。在20世纪20年代的哈莱姆区，它只接待白人顾客。你有黑人艺人和黑人服务人员，你知道，员工，但顾客只有白人。这在美国各地都是如此。所以肤色限制，它在北方没有那么僵化。
And it was much more, you know, location by location. And so you didn't necessarily have white water fountains and black water fountains the way that you did in the South. But you definitely had whites-only restaurants, whites-only. And across the Midwest, for example, whites- only, you know, diners and things like that. So it went on through the civil rights era. And that's why the civil rights wasn't just a phenomenon in the South. It was a phenomenon across the country for exactly that reason. So here's a question, Sarah. You can see why white Southerners, you know, you don't have to
它更多的是，你知道，因地而异。所以你并不一定有像南方那样的白人饮水机和黑人饮水机。但你绝对有只接待白人的餐馆，只接待白人的。在中西部，例如，只接待白人的餐馆等等。所以它一直持续到民权运动时期。这就是为什么民权运动不仅仅是南方的一种现象。它在全国各地都是一种现象，正是因为这个原因。所以这里有一个问题，萨拉。你可以看出为什么南方白人，你知道，你不需要
be a genius to work out why white Southerners like Gone with the Wind. It's a romantic, nostalgic evocation of what they see as their areas, their regions past. And we can go into- And their birthright. Right. And I'm sure we'll go into dissecting all the issues with that. The question is why people in the North, we've done four episodes on the Civil War.
是天才就能算出为什么南方白人喜欢《乱世佳人》。这是一个浪漫的、怀旧的对他们所认为的地区过去的唤起。我们可以深入探讨——以及他们的与生俱来的权利。没错。我相信我们会去剖析其中的所有问题。问题是为什么北方的人，我们已经制作了四集关于内战的节目。
We've talked about the massive casualty rates, the horrendous treatment of prisoners, all of these things um this is within living memory you know you can still be old enough to remember the civil war in the late 1930s i think just about so why is it that people in i don't know in boston in new york in chicago wherever are flocking to this film in a in an, in, in, in apparently, um, you know, a sort of guilt-free, shame-free, non-critical way, lapping up the Southern bells, loving Vivian Leigh as Scarlett O'Hara, loving Clark Gable, or am I wrong? And are, do people have issues with it?
我们谈到了巨大的伤亡率，对囚犯的恐怖待遇，所有这些事情，这在有生之年，你知道，你可能年纪大到在20世纪30年代末还记得内战，我想差不多。所以为什么在波士顿、纽约、芝加哥等地的人们会蜂拥去看这部电影，以一种，显然，你知道，一种无罪恶感、无羞耻感、非批判性的方式，沉迷于南方淑女，喜爱费雯·丽饰演的斯嘉丽·奥哈拉，喜爱克拉克·盖博，还是我错了？人们对它有意见吗？
No, um, you're not wrong. And the, the main people who had issues with it were, as I've already said, African-Americans, they were very outspoken at the time in their resistance to the film. There were a handful of white critics in the North and the South who pointed out what absolute garbage it was historically, how inaccurate it was, but also that it was deeply problematic. But for the most part, white people were very happy to go watch it. And the answer to that, I can put it very briefly as an assertion, but people may or may not believe me, but part of what my book is about is making the case for what I'm now going to assert, which is that the reason they were okay with it was
不，你没错。正如我已经说过的，对它有意见的主要群体是非裔美国人，他们在当时对电影的抵制非常直言不讳。在北方和南方都有少数白人评论家指出它在历史上是多么垃圾，它是多么不准确，而且它存在严重的问题。但大多数白人非常乐意去看它。对此的回答，我可以简短地断言，人们可能会或可能不会相信我，但我书的一部分就是为我现在要断言的内容辩护，那就是他们对它没意见的原因是
because the country reunited after the Civil War around white supremacism. Because the key thing here to remember is that, first of all, it's not even true that the war was fought by the North to end slavery. They didn't begin the war, as I'm sure you've covered in your podcast, which have not yet gone out yet, which is why I don't know. I will, of course, be avidly listening. But that, you know, the North didn't enter the war to abolish slavery. It entered the war to hold the union together. And the fight, the conflict was over the question of slavery, absolutely. But they didn't enter it to create abolition, to affect abolition. As I say in the book, that's why they were the Union Army and not
因为国家在内战后围绕白人至上主义重新统一了。因为这里要记住的关键是，首先，北方为了结束奴隶制而进行战争甚至都不是真的。他们并没有开始这场战争，正如我相信你们在播客中已经涵盖的那样，虽然还没发布，所以我不知道。我当然会热切地收听。但，你知道，北方并没有为了废除奴隶制而进入战争。它进入战争是为了保持联邦的统一。而冲突，冲突是关于奴隶制的问题，绝对是。但他们进入战争并不是为了创造废奴，为了实现废奴。正如我在书中说的，这就是为什么他们是联邦军而不是
the abolitionists, right? So the fight originally was to hold the country together. And abolition became a necessary thing to do in order for that to happen. And certainly the fight was over the expansion of slavery and whether slavery should continue in the United States. That was absolutely the core of the battle. But the key is that you can think that slavery is wrong and be okay with racism. And that's the key, is that you can think that Black people are inherently inferior and just think that slavery is a moral abomination. So you may think that Black people have a right to not be enslaved, but not that they are your equal and not that they have a right to all of the same entitlements and prerogatives that you have. And that was the preponderant feeling among a great many white people at the time in North
废奴主义者，对吧？所以最初的斗争是为了保持国家的统一。而废奴成为了实现这一目标所必需的事情。当然，斗争是关于奴隶制的扩张以及奴隶制是否应该在美国继续存在。这绝对是战斗的核心。但关键在于，你可以认为奴隶制是错误的，同时对种族主义没意见。这就是关键，你可以认为黑人天生低劣，只是认为奴隶制是一种道德上的憎恶。所以你可能认为黑人有不被奴役的权利，但并不认为他们是你的平等者，也不认为他们有权享有你所拥有的所有相同的权利和特权。这就是当时北方和南方许多白人的主要感受。所以，在几十年间，我们应该再次给出锚定日期，对吧？所以内战在1865年结束，《乱世佳人》在1936年出版。所以在那个70年的时间里，正如你所说，也许还有几个人活着。他们大多数已经死了，但白人继承的是一个故事，为了让国家重新团结起来，它必须，好吧，它不一定必须，但它确实决定说服自己，奴隶制无论如何并没有那么糟糕。而且因为美国无论如何是一个可爱的地方。所以每个人都聚在一起相信，实际上，奴隶制真的是一件大事吗？不，我不确定它是。所以在那样的心态下，你可以去看《乱世佳人》并享受它。所以萨拉，在你的书中，你总结说
and South. And so over several decades between, and we should give people the anchor dates again, right? So the Civil War ends in 1865, Gone with the Winds comes out in 1936. So in that 70 year period, as you say, maybe a few people were still alive. Most of them were dead, but what white people had inherited instead was a story in order for the country to come back together again, it had to, well, it didn't have to, but it did decide to convince itself that slavery hadn't really been that bad anyway. And because America is, you know, a lovely place anyway. And so everybody came together believing that actually, was slavery such a big deal? No, I'm not sure it was. And so in that mindset, you can go watch Gone with the Wind and enjoy it. So Sarah, in your book, you sum it up by saying
奴隶制被战争废除了，但白人至上主义没有。是的，完全正确。那么《乱世佳人》为那个过程提供了什么镜子？内战后南方发生了什么？然后，玛格丽特·米切尔举起这面镜子，这说明了30年代的态度是什么？首先，关于内战后发生的事情，《乱世佳人》揭示了什么准确的内容？那将是一个简短的回答，萨拉。是的，完全正确。
slavery was abolished by the war, but white supremacy was not. Yeah, exactly. So what mirror does Gone With the Wind hold up to that process? What happened in the South in the aftermath of the Civil War? And then what does that, the fact that Margaret Mitchell is holding this mirror up, what does that say about attitudes in the 30s? So first of all, what has gone with the wind revealing that is accurate about what happened in the aftermath? That'll be a short answer, Sarah. Yeah, exactly.
内战的。但你说，你知道，你用这本书来展示内战后存在的所有这些态度在30年代仍然普遍存在。是的。所以我知道，我可以回答这个问题。所以我会说，它所讲述的真实之处在于它展示了南方白人的心态。这就是我们必须，我相信，仍然要理解的。所以斯嘉丽认为自己是内战的受害者。我想要重构的关键点是不断提醒我的读者，这是一场斯嘉丽的社会为了捍卫一种不可辩护的生活方式而发动的战争，那就是维持黑人奴隶制。斯嘉丽和她的朋友及家人
Of the Civil War. But you're saying, you know, you're using the book to show that all these kinds of attitudes that were there in the aftermath of the Civil War is still prevalent in the 1930s. Yeah. So I know and I can answer this. So the answer I would say is that what it told that was was truthful was it showed the mindset of white Southerners. And that's what we had. We must still, I believe, understand. So Scarlett sees herself as the victim of the Civil War. And the key thing that I want to do to reframe this is to keep reminding my reader that this was a war that Scarlet's society started in order to defend an indefensible way of life, which was to maintain Black slavery. Scarlet and her friends and family
非常把自己视为受害者。他们是整个过程中受害的人。汤姆，你在我们讨论开始时说她想让她的生活重回正轨。那是她的观点。但我的观点是她想夺回她的权力。她失去了所有的权力，她想夺回来。她想再次变得富有。她想再次拥有奴隶。她不能合法地拥有奴隶。但故事所展示的是，我给出了很多例子，斯嘉丽的权力幻想从来不仅仅是拿回她的钱和房子。它们总是与让黑人再次在土地上劳作的幻想纠缠在一起。她一遍又一遍地用这些话说了出来。
very much see themselves as the victims. They are the ones who were victimized by this whole process. And Tom, you said at the beginning of our discussion that she wants to get her life back on an even keel. That's her point of view. But my point of view is that she wants to reclaim her power. She lost all of her power and she wants it back. She wants to be rich again. She wants to have slaves again. And she can't have slaves legally. But what the story shows is, and I kind of give lots of examples of this, is that Scarlet's fantasies of power are never just getting her money and her house back. They're always entangled with fantasies of having black people working the land again. And she says that in so many words over and over and over again.
她说，除非黑人的手，而不是白人的手，在塔拉庄园采摘棉花，否则她永远不会再觉得自己是一位淑女。所以有一个基于种族的秩序，她决心恢复。它所捕捉到的心态是美国白人开始把自己视为种族平等的受害者，任何向民权运动迈进的受害者的时刻。当然，黑人在内战后的美国南方没有权力。所以我在书中做的一件事是事实与虚构，这真的是它的设置。所以我展示了米切尔声称的内容
She says she would never feel like a lady again until black hands, not white, were picking cotton at Tara. So there is a race-based order that she is determined to restore. And the mindset that it captures is this moment when white people in America began to see themselves as the victims of racial equality, of the victims of any movement towards civil rights. And of course, black people do not have the power in the post-Civil War American South. And so one of the things that I'm doing in the book is kind of fact versus fiction is really the setup of it. So I show what Mitchell claims
然后深入文献历史来说明记录显示了什么。黑人非常，所以在斯嘉丽的脑海中，黑人突然统治了南方。黑人并没有统治南方。所以他们所指的，他们在历史上确实指的，是所谓的“黑人统治（Negro rule）”，所以白人在非裔美国人的控制之下，他们所指的“黑人统治”并认为完全不可接受的是一个黑人立法者或两个黑人立法者。这是在所谓的代表性多种族民主中拥有任何黑人
and then go into documentary history to say what the record shows. And black people are very, so in Scarlett's mind, black people are suddenly running the South. Black people weren't running the South. So what they refer to, and they did refer to historically, as quote unquote Negro rule, so white people under the thumb of African Americans, what they refer to as Negro rule and saw as completely unacceptable was one Black legislator or two Black legislators. It was having any black
的存在。他们认为这是一种完全不可接受的状态。这就是他们所拒绝的社会。她和她的朋友们决心以他们能做到的尽可能多的方式重建战前白人奴隶制南方的特权。这确实是南方白人在内战后所做的。你说，你知道，你想让我们了解历史。所以我认为我们可能必须深入探讨，那就是当时发生了什么。南方白人着手重建尽可能多的奴隶制种族等级结构，除了没有奴隶制。所以奴隶主、种植园主所面临的问题，
people in a supposedly representative multiracial democracy at all. And they saw that as a completely unacceptable state of affairs. And that is the society that they are rejecting. And she and her friends are determined to recreate the privileges of antebellum white slaveholding South in as many ways as they can. And that is indeed what the white South did in the aftermath of the Civil War. And you said, you know, you wanted to catch us up on the history. So I think we probably have to go into that is what happened then. The white South set about recreating as many of the structures of the racial hierarchies of slavery as they could, except without slavery. So the problem that is faced by the slave owners, the plantocracy,
一旦他们失去了权力，一旦他们在内战中被击败，从他们的角度来看，就是那些曾经是他们奴隶的人不仅获得了自由，而且获得了投票权。是的，权力，因此在代议制民主中拥有权力。所以如果你想重建一个尽可能接近内战前存在的社会，因此你必须恐吓、重组基本的政治权利等等，以便整个社会的一部分无法获得它们。好吧，那开始得太快了，我的意思是，三K党，最著名的例子，是在1865年底成立的，我的意思是，他们甚至没有等待。是的，但是的，完全正确，一年。所以，完全正确，这就是。
once they've lost power, once they've been defeated in the Civil War, from their point of view, is that people who were formerly their slaves have not only been freed, but been given the vote. Yeah, and power, therefore power in a representative democracy. And so if you want to kind of have to recreate a society that approximates as closely as possible to the society that existed before the Civil War, therefore you have to intimidate, restructure fundamental political rights and so on, so that an entire section of that society is unable to access them well that starts so quickly though i mean the clan the most famous example of that is founded in the end of 1865 i mean they don't even wait yeah but yeah exactly one year yeah so exactly and so that's
一旦他们失去了权力，一旦他们在内战中被击败，从他们的角度来看，那些曾经是他们奴隶的人不仅获得了自由，还获得了投票权。是的，因此在代议制民主中获得了权力。所以，如果你想重建一个尽可能接近内战前存在的社会，你就必须进行恐吓、重构基本的政治权利等等，这样社会的一个完整部分就无法获得这些权利。但这开始得太快了，我的意思是，最著名的例子三K党成立于1865年底，他们甚至都没有等待，是的，确实，仅仅一年，所以完全正确，这就是
it and this is really really crucial for people to understand is that the the clan and and this gets really complicated because there have been different iterations of the clan, but the original clan, and this is one of the things I show at great length in the book because I think it's so important and it's been lost to most people's understanding of the first clan. It was set up with the explicit intent to disenfranchise black Americans. It was there to remove their ability to vote. That's what it was for. And that's what they did. So Sarah, could we take a break now? But when we come back, could we follow this story through?
这对于人们理解至关重要，那就是三K党——这变得非常复杂，因为三K党经历过不同的迭代，但最初的三K党，这也是我在书中详尽展示的内容之一，因为我认为它太重要了，而且大多数人对最初的三K党的理解已经缺失了。它的成立有着明确的意图，即剥夺美国黑人的公民权。它的存在是为了消除他们的投票能力。这就是它的目的。而他们也确实做到了。那么萨拉，我们现在可以休息一下吗？但回来后，我们能继续讲这个故事吗？
So the Ku Klux Klan, Jim Crow, all that kind of stuff, how it was that a kind of simulacrum of slavery was reconstructed in the aftermath of the Civil War and take us through that story up to Gone with the Wind. So thanks very much for listening. We'll see you after the break. slavery was reconstructed in the aftermath of the Civil War and take us through that story up to up to this up to Gone With The Wind so thanks very much for listening we'll see you after the break I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our Members Club.
所以三K党、吉姆·克劳法，所有这些东西，以及内战后奴隶制的一种模拟物是如何被重建的，请带我们梳理一下这段历史，一直讲到《乱世佳人》。非常感谢大家的收听。我们休息后再见。奴隶制在内战后被重建，请带我们梳理一下这段历史，一直讲到《乱世佳人》。非常感谢大家的收听，我们休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about Gone With The Wind, the lost cause of the Confederacy and memories of the American Civil War.
如果你想收听无广告内容、额外剧集并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们正在讨论《乱世佳人》、邦联的“迷途事业”以及对美国内战的记忆。
So Sarah Churchwell, Gone With The Wind takes about 17 hours to explore what happens in the aftermath of the American Civil War and the defeat, effectively, of Reconstruction. The defeat of the attempt to give people who had formerly been slaves full political and particularly voting rights in what had been the Confederacy. So Gone with the Wind sort of goes into that, but it tells it from a very, very particular point of view. So, I mean, my take on this would be that the attempt to reconstruct was always doomed to fail because the North was never prepared to put in enough troops to make it work. And we talked about this in our last Civil War episode.
那么萨拉·彻奇韦尔，《乱世佳人》花了大约17个小时来探讨美国内战后的余波，以及重建工作的彻底失败。即试图给予曾经的奴隶完全的政治权利，特别是投票权的尝试在曾经的邦联地区失败了。所以《乱世佳人》某种程度上涉及了这一点，但它从一个非常、非常特殊的角度来讲述。我的看法是，重建的尝试注定要失败，因为北方从未准备好投入足够的军队来使其奏效。我们在上一期内战节目中讨论过这个问题。
What's your take? Do you think this is something that could have worked or do you think it was doomed to fail? I think it probably was doomed to fail, but I love the audacity of it. And I'd like to give a little bit more credit to that. Because what we have as a country, and what an experiment, right, to try to go from race based slavery, to full multiracial democracy, in the space of a couple of years, like, there's a part of me is I'm quite proud of that as an American, you know, like, well, good on us, you know, I mean, you got to give them credit for trying. But for me, it was doomed to failure, not only because the North wouldn't make sufficient
你的看法呢？你认为这是一件可能成功的事情，还是你认为它注定要失败？我认为它可能注定要失败，但我喜欢它的胆识。我想对此给予更多的肯定。因为作为一个国家，我们拥有什么，这是一场多么伟大的实验，对吧？在短短几年内，试图从基于种族的奴隶制转向完全的多种族民主，我内心深处作为一个美国人对此感到相当自豪，你知道，就像，干得好，你知道，我的意思是，你必须为他们的尝试给予肯定。但对我来说，它注定要失败，不仅是因为北方不会投入足够的
investment, and you're absolutely right, that was crucial. But because the, you know, the problems of reunifying the country after the Civil War went beyond that, you can't just have an occupying force in your own country indefinitely. So what was that supposed to look like? And of course, that doesn't look like peace, whatever else it looks like, if there is an occupying force from the North, it doesn't look like peace. And you're trying to create peace and to reunify, to genuinely reunify. And what does that look like? But for me, the other reason why it was doomed to failure is that these are people who went to war to defend race-based slavery. And then you tell them to become effectively 21st century multiracial, you know, we would say Democrats, but I mean, small d Democrats. Of course,
投资，你说得完全正确，那至关重要。而且因为，你知道，内战后国家统一的问题远不止于此，你不能无限期地在自己的国家驻扎占领军。那么那应该是什么样子呢？当然，如果北方有占领军，那看起来并不像和平，无论它看起来像什么，它都不像和平。你试图创造和平并实现统一，真正地实现统一。那看起来是什么样子呢？但对我来说，它注定失败的另一个原因是，这些人是为了捍卫基于种族的奴隶制而参战的。然后你告诉他们要变成实际上21世纪的多种族，你知道，我们会说是民主党人，但我的意思是，小写的d民主主义者。当然，
they weren't going to do that. I mean, it's such an idealized idea that they would do that in the first place. But the thing for us to bear in mind as we understand what happened to Black people in the immediate aftermath of the Civil War, is that the franchise was not removed from them simply by hook or by crook, although the plantocracy did everything that they could think of, the slavocracy, any way that they could. But murder was fine, too. Right. And so we need to remember that they were killing black legislators in broad daylight, just shooting them down. When you say they, do you mean the Ku Klux Klan?
他们是不会那样做的。我的意思是，他们会那样做本身就是一个理想化的想法。但我们在理解内战后黑人立即遭遇了什么时，需要记住的一点是，他们的选举权并不是简单地通过某种手段被剥夺的，尽管种植园主阶级想尽了一切办法，奴隶主阶级，任何他们能想到的方式。但谋杀也是可以的，对吧？所以我们需要记住，他们在大白天杀害黑人立法者，直接把他们枪杀。当你说是他们时，你是指三K党吗？
Well, no, I mean white supremacists. So they may or may not have been members of the Klan. The Klan was just one of many white supremacist groups. There are lots of paramilitary groups, aren't there? So the Klan is just one of many white supremacist paramilitary groups that emerged at the time. It's just the most famous and the most mythologized, partly thanks to stories like Gone with the Wind. Because Ashley is a member of it, right? Ashley is the leader of the Atlantic, of the Georgia clan.
嗯，不，我是指白人至上主义者。所以他们可能是也可能不是三K党成员。三K党只是众多白人至上主义团体中的一个。有很多准军事组织，不是吗？所以三K党只是当时出现的众多白人至上主义准军事组织之一。它只是最著名、被神话得最多的一个，部分归功于像《乱世佳人》这样的故事。因为阿什利是其中的一员，对吧？阿什利是亚特兰大、佐治亚州三K党的领导人。
And that's really, really important. And in the novel, that's completely explicit. In the film, it's euphemized. But in the novel, it's totally explicit. He and Scarlett's second husband, Frank Kennedy, are members of the clan. Rhett Butler is not a member of the clan, but he sympathizes with its aims and desires. He's just not, he's not a group joiner, you know. He shoots a black person for being uppity.
这非常、非常重要。在小说中，这一点完全是明确的。在电影中，它被委婉化了。但在小说中，它是完全明确的。他和斯嘉丽的第二任丈夫弗兰克·肯尼迪都是三K党成员。瑞德·巴特勒不是三K党成员，但他同情其目标和愿望。他只是，他不是那种喜欢加入团体的人，你知道。他枪杀了一个黑人，因为对方“傲慢”。
We don't know that he shoots them, but he lynches a black man for being, quote, uppity to a lady. So we know that he murdered a black man and he admits to it, but we don't know how he killed him. He may have hanged him. He may have shot him, whatever. He may have tortured him. We don't know. The story doesn't say. But there were many other paramilitary groups, and it's important to understand this. There was the Knights of the White Camellia, there was the White League, there were the Red Shirts, there were many others. And many of those groups were reinvented in the interwar years, in the years of American fascism, which is part of another story of American history that has been suppressed and one that I do bring into the book because I think it's so important
我们不知道他是否枪杀了他们，但他私刑处死了一个黑人，因为他被认为对一位女士“傲慢”。所以我们知道他谋杀了一个黑人，他也承认了，但我们不知道他是怎么杀的。他可能绞死了他。他可能枪杀了他，无论怎样。他可能折磨了他。我们不知道。故事里没说。但还有许多其他准军事组织，理解这一点很重要。有“白茶花骑士团”，有“白人联盟”，有“红衫军”，还有许多其他组织。其中许多组织在两次世界大战之间，在美国法西斯主义时期被重组，这是美国历史上被压制的另一个故事的一部分，我确实把它写进了书里，因为我认为它非常重要
here in bridging these eras. And so the people who were murdering Black legislators in broad daylight may or may not have been members of particular paramilitary groups. They didn't self-identify, but they could also have just been white supremacists who just walked up and shot them in cold blood in the name of the old South, in the name of restoring their own power. And then all of the white, you know, plantocracy, they all, you know, self, you know, protected each other. And so what is, I mean, what are the police doing? I mean, this is a really naive question, I suppose. Are there no frameworks of law and order? Oh, totally break down. The police are white supremacists too, right? So-
在这里连接这些时代。所以那些在大白天谋杀黑人立法者的人，可能也可能不是特定准军事组织的成员。他们没有自我认同，但他们也可能只是白人至上主义者，他们只是走过去，以旧南方的名义，以恢复他们自身权力的名义，冷血地枪杀了他们。然后所有的白人，你知道，种植园主阶级，他们都，你知道，自我，你知道，互相保护。那么，我的意思是，警察在做什么？我的意思是，这可能是一个非常天真的问题。难道没有法律和秩序的框架吗？哦，完全崩溃了。警察也是白人至上主义者，对吧？所以——
But that goes right on right into the 60s, Tom. Yeah, I know. I know, but I just- It goes on now. It goes on now. So exactly. But so no, this is crucial, right? So what we would think of as law and order in the South totally breaks down. When the North moves in, I mean, putting my hands up, I know nothing about this period at all. So Reconstruction is basically the attempt to bring in frameworks of law and order that would enable Black people to exercise their civic rights. And the failure of reconstruction is that basically people in the North just wash their hands of it and give up because it's too complicated. But it's not just that, Tom.
但这一直持续到60年代，汤姆。是的，我知道。我知道，但我只是——这现在还在继续。这现在还在继续。所以完全正确。但所以不，这至关重要，对吧？所以我们认为南方的法律和秩序完全崩溃了。当北方进入时，我的意思是，举手投降，我对这段时期一无所知。所以重建基本上是试图引入法律和秩序的框架，使黑人能够行使他们的公民权利。而重建的失败在于，基本上北方的人们只是洗手不干，放弃了，因为它太复杂了。但不仅如此，汤姆。
I would say, Sarah may disagree, I would say a successful reconstruction would rely on the support of Southern elites. I mean, as any form of occupation does, as any empire or any military occupation, you need to co-opt the powerful people in that community or a degree of support in that community to make it work so you don't have to do it as it were at the point of a bayonet yeah and surely the issue in the south is exactly what sarah says that there are just far i mean as people given that they've already fought a war to defend this institution they're not going to say within six months oh yeah you're actually right fine i forget what i've previously my best friend yeah you know exactly and so that's and this institution, they're not going to say within six months, oh yeah, you're actually right. Fine.
我会说，萨拉可能会不同意，我会说成功的重建将依赖于南方精英的支持。我的意思是，正如任何形式的占领一样，正如任何帝国或任何军事占领一样，你需要拉拢那个社区中有权势的人，或者在那个社区中获得一定程度的支持，才能使其奏效，这样你就不用像那样，在刺刀下进行。是的，南方的问题肯定正是萨拉所说的，因为人数太多了，我的意思是，考虑到他们已经打了一场战争来捍卫这种制度，他们不会在六个月内说，哦，是的，你是对的，好吧，我忘了我之前……我最好的朋友，是的，你知道，完全正确。所以那是，而且绝对，我完全同意多米尼克。问题在于内战在这一点上一直在进行，只是通过代理人战争，通过小规模冲突。有大量的暴力事件，有些比其他的更有组织。在大多数选举中，内战后的后续选举中都有骚乱。当时有针对黑人的大屠杀。我的意思是，当他们试图行使投票权时，他们遭到了屠杀。所以这不仅仅是北方能做什么的问题，但你必须记住，警察是地方
I forget what I've previously been. Be my best friend. Yeah. You know, exactly. And so that's, and absolutely, I completely agree with Dominic. And the problem is that the civil war keeps being fought at this point, but just through proxy battles, through skirmishes. There was an enormous amount of violence, some of it more organized than others. There were riots around most of the elections, the subsequent elections after the Civil War. There were massacres of Black people at the time. I mean, they were massacred when they attempted to exercise the vote. So it isn't just a question of what could the North have been doing, but you've got to remember that the police are local
美国的武装力量。而且他们也是——而且他们是由美国选举产生的，他们有点像警长。嗯，是的，在不同的地方设置不同。有不同的规则，但完全正确。所以他们也是白人至上主义者。我的意思是，我讲了一个故事，这是一个可怕的故事，但我讲的故事之一是在书中，关于一个黑人被带出去进行私刑处死。他最终没有被杀，但他受到了折磨和残害。
forces in the United States. And they were also- And they're elected by the United States, they're kind of sheriffs. Well, yeah, and it's all set up differently in different places. There are different rules for it, but exactly. And so they were white supremacists too. I mean, I tell the story, it's a terrible story, but one of the stories I tell is in the book is of a black man who was taken out to be lynched. He was ultimately not killed, but he was tortured and maimed.
我不知道你的听众胃口有多大，但如果你不想让我说，你可以把它剪掉，但他被阉割了。他在寒冷中被剥光了衣服。然后，你知道，他们把他扔进了树林。他走了两英里才找到最近的医生。而医生不在家，因为医生就是袭击他的三K党成员之一。对吧？这就是你所说的根深蒂固的暴力和白人至上主义。你去法院，你会发现警察就是刚才在树林里袭击你的那些家伙。是的。好的。那么，吉姆·克劳。所以到底，吉姆·克劳到底是谁？我一直很好奇，我的意思是，我知道你在书里告诉了我们，这就是为什么其中一个
I don't know how strong stomach your listeners have, but you can edit this out if you don't want me to say, but he was castrated. And he was stripped naked in the cold. And then, you know, they sent him off into the woods. And he walked two miles to find the nearest doctor. And the doctor wasn't at home because the doctor had been one of the members of the Klan who attacked him. Right? This is the kind of entrenched violence and white supremacism that you're talking about. You go to the courthouse and you'll find that the police are the guys who just attacked you in the woods. Yeah. Okay. So, and Jim Crow. So what exactly, who exactly is Jim Crow? I've always wondered, I mean, I know you tell us in the book, which is why one of the
我从书中了解到的许多事情，我一直很好奇。但许多听众可能不知道吉姆·克劳是谁或是什么。所以是的，吉姆·克劳是一个非裔美国人的捣蛋鬼形象，就像布雷尔兔一样。所以他是一个民间传说人物，代表了西非民间传说与奴隶经历的一种融合。所以这些非裔美国人的传说和故事得到了发展。关于那段历史，许多学者在过去几十年里研究过，其中美妙的一点是，那种娱乐运作的方式是，白人认为，哦，看，奴隶们只是用他们讲述的这些故事来娱乐自己。
many things that I learned from the book, I'd always wondered that. But many of the listeners may not know who or what Jim Crow is. So yeah, so Jim Crow is an African American trickster figure like Brer Rabbit. So he's a folklore figure that any any represents a kind of a fusion of West African folklore with the slave experience. And so these African American legends and stories get developed. And one of the things that's wonderful about that history that many, many scholars have worked on over now many decades is that for the way that that entertainment worked was that white people saw it as, oh, look, the slaves are just entertaining themselves with these stories that they're telling.
但这些故事里有关于黑人力量、自由、解放以及如何智胜俘虏者的深度编码信息。这些通常是关于智胜俘虏者的故事。所以奴隶制，被奴役的经历，嵌入到了这些故事中。而这些捣蛋鬼形象是那些能够从权势者手中逃脱的人，他们是能够规避权力结构的人。所以吉姆·克劳是一个民间传说人物。在19世纪的美国，有一种
But the stories had deeply coded messages about Black power and about freedom and about liberty and about how you outwit your captor. These are often stories about outwitting captors. And so slavery, the experience of being enslaved, embeds itself into these stories. And these trickster figures are the ones who can get away from the powerful, and they're the ones who can evade the structures of power. So Jim Crow was a folklore figure. And in the 19th century in America, there was an
极其流行的娱乐形式，被称为“吟游诗人表演”。英国听众可能还记得70年代的《黑白吟游诗人秀》。同样的事情，涂黑脸的娱乐表演，但它来自内战前的美国。而吉姆·克劳是给那些吟游诗人表演起的名字。它只是通过，再次，通过某种流行文化。它只是成为了用法，人们开始用它来描述它们。有一个，我在书里深入探讨过，这对我们现在的目的可能不重要，但有一个特别著名的涂黑脸的白人艺人，他采用了吉姆·克劳的形象，并变得非常出名。有一首流行的歌和一个流行的舞蹈。然后随着
enormously popular kind of entertainment, became known as minstrelsy. British listeners may remember the Black and White Minstrel Show from the 70s. Same thing, blackface entertainments, but it came from antebellum America. And Jim Crow was the name that was given to those minstrel entertainments. It just came through, again, through kind of popular culture. It just became the usage and people started using it to describe them. There was one, I go into this in the book, it's probably not important for our purposes now, but there was one particularly famous blackface white entertainer who adopted the persona of Jim Crow and became very famous. And there was a popular song and a popular dance. And then as
内战后白人南方重新强加种族等级制度，他们开始，再次，只是口语化地，人们开始使用“吉姆·克劳”这个短语来描述这些。我们一直在比较松散地谈论重建，但同样，给人们一些日期可能会有帮助，对吧？这样我们在谈话中就有了一些锚点。我们通常谈论的方式是，重建从1865年内战结束持续到1877年的妥协。1877年发生的事情是一场有争议的选举。这对今天的听众来说应该听起来很熟悉。2020年绝不是第一次有争议的选举，2000年也不是。1876年是一场有争议的
the structures of racial hierarchies were reimposed in the white South after the Civil War, they began, again, just kind of colloquially, people started using the phrase Jim Crow to describe these. And we've been talking a little bit loosely about Reconstruction, but again, it might be helpful to give people some dates, right? So that we've got a kind of some anchor points in the conversation. So the ways that we would normally talk about it is Reconstruction lasts from the end of the Civil War in 1865 to the compromise of 1877. And what happened in 1877 was there was a contested election. That should sound familiar to listeners today. 2020 was by no means the first contested election, nor was 2000 for that matter. 1876 was a contested
选举。事实是，民主党人，我们也应该暂停一下说这个，这非常复杂，但对于，我相信你在内战剧集中讲过，但对于听众来说，始终理解这一点很重要，即在19世纪的美国，两党在民权和种族平等问题上的立场是相反的。所以南方民主党人是农业南方、奴隶主阶级、白人至上主义的政党，而共和党人是林肯的政党，是废奴和民权的政党。
election. And the truth is, is that the Democrats, which were, we should also pause and say this, it's very complicated, but it's important for, and I'm sure you went through this in your Civil War episodes, but it's important for listeners to always understand that in 19th century America, the two parties have a reversed position around civil rights and racial equality. So the Southern Democrats were the party of the agrarian South of the slavocracy of white supremacism, and the Republicans were the party of Lincoln and the party of abolition and civil rights.
所以1876年有争议的选举中发生的事情是，南方民主党人可能赢了。白人至上主义者可能赢了，但选举是有争议的，选举很可疑，没有人相信这些地方选举的结果。所以发生的事情是国会必须在联邦层面想出一个解决方案。他们提出了所谓的1877年妥协，
And so what happens in the contested election of 1876 is that the Southern Democrats probably won. The white supremacists probably won, but it was contested and the elections were dodgy and nobody trusted the outcomes of these local elections. And so what happened was Congress had to come up with a solution on the federal level. And they came up with what's known as the Compromise of 1877,
南方民主党人同意让共和党候选人成为总统，那就是拉瑟福德·B·海斯。但他们这样做是为了换取联邦军队从深南地区撤出。在那一刻，重建结束了。不再有任何联邦尝试来执行内战修正案，特别是民权。它们是第一批民权修正案，赋予黑人投票权并以各种其他方式保护他们。所以白人北方在那一刻撤出，基本上让白人南方自生自灭，随心所欲。做你们自己的事。去狂欢吧。并绝对抛弃了黑人，抛弃了非裔美国人，让他们面对顽固的白人至上主义深南地区。在那一刻，我们所知道的吉姆·克劳开始真正建立起来。
where the Southern Democrats agreed that they would let the Republican candidate become president. and that was Rutherford B. Hayes. But they did so in exchange for the withdrawal of federal troops from the Deep South. And at that point, Reconstruction was over. There was no longer any federal attempt to enforce the Civil War amendments, and particularly the Civil Rights. They were the first Civil Rights amendments, giving Black people the vote and protecting them in various other ways. So the white North withdraws at that point and basically leaves the white South to itself, to its own devices. Do your own thing. Go wild. And absolutely abandons Black people, abandons African-Americans to the intransigent white supremacist deep South. And at that point, what we know is Jim Crow begins to really get built.
所以他们，尽管他们开始得很早，他们在那一刻尽可能快地开始了，它开始被合法化，并且，并且，并且创造了结构，这些结构将成为，将成为，20世纪头几十年我们所知道的种族隔离社会。所以这在1900年左右就完成了。而这显然是你得到建设的时期
So they, although they started early, they started as fast as they could at this point, it starts to get legalized and, and, and the structures are created that would become the, the, the society, the racially segregated society of the early decades of the 20th century that, that we know. So that's complete by about 1900 or so. And that's obviously the period at which you get the building decades of the 20th century that we know. So that's complete by about 1900 or so.
20世纪的几十年，我们所知道的。所以这在1900年左右就完成了。而这显然是你得到建设所有邦联雕像的时期。完全正确。你得到了某种创造，对“迷途事业”神话的巩固，这基本上是《乱世佳人》所体现的，不是吗？完全正确。你得到了一个关键决定
And that's obviously the period at which you get the building of all the Confederate statues. Exactly. You get the sort of creation, the entrenching of the lost cause myth, which Gone with the Wind basically incarnates, doesn't it? Exactly. And you get one key decision
许多听众会知道是在这个时期出现的，那就是1896年的普莱西诉弗格森最高法院判决，它说“隔离但平等”。这就是合法化种族隔离的东西。在那一点上，从1896年开始，种族隔离是合法的，直到1965年被《民权法案》废除。所以从1896年到1965年，种族隔离在美国是合法的。这就是为什么回到之前关于为什么它不仅仅在南方的问题上。因为最高法院在1896年将其合法化了。所以萨拉，“迷途事业”神话。
that many of your listeners will know comes in this period, which is the 1896 Plessy v. Ferguson Supreme Court decision that says that separate can be equal. And that's what legalized segregation. And at that point, racial segregation from 1896 is legal until it's reversed by the Civil Rights Acts of 1965. So between 1896 and 1965, racial segregation is legal in the United States. And that's why to the earlier point about why wasn't it only in the South? Because the Supreme Court legalized it in 1896. So Sarah, the lost cause myth.
我的意思是，我开始时读了关于，你知道，骑士和所有这些沃尔特·司各特的《艾凡赫》。是的，它确实是沃尔特·司各特。我们在内战剧集中稍微讨论过这一点，是的，它被称为沃尔特·司各特。所以这里有一个问题。汤姆·麦克泰格，我们的听众之一，为《大西洋月刊》撰稿，他问到神话作为羞耻的遮羞布。这是一个作为羞耻遮羞布的国家神话的好例子吗？因为我不知道白人南方人是否真的对这件事感到羞耻。我的意思是，假设在1900年或1930年或1940年，他们感到羞耻吗？他们对奴隶制和内战感到内疚吗？还是他们认为那是一个伟大的制度，那是一个崇高的事业，输了很可惜，但你知道，我们只是必须继续前进。你觉得呢？你
I mean, I started this by reading that stuff about, you know, Cavaliers and all this sort of Cod Walter Scott, Ivanhoe. Yeah, it is Cod Walter Scott. And we talked about that a little bit in our Civil War episodes, Yeah, it is called Walter Scott. So here's a question. And so Tom McTague, who's one of our listeners who writes for The Atlantic, he asked about myths as cover for shame. Is this a good example of a national myth that's a cover for shame? because I don't know whether people in the white southerners do feel ashamed about this. I mean, let's say in 1900 or 1930 or 1940, do they feel ashamed? Do they feel guilty about slavery and about the civil war? Or do they think that was a great institution and that was a noble cause and it's a shame we lost, but you know, we just have to kind of crack on. What do you think? Do you
认为他们感到内疚吗？不，我认为你说得完全正确。我认为他们感到自我正当化，他们所做的是在他们自己的个人心理自我正当化和对所作所为的合理化中加倍努力。但他们这样做是为了抵御羞耻。他们这样做是为了抵御内疚。所以我们可以谈谈个人对此可能有何感受。但他们这样做是为了抵御羞耻。他们这样做是为了抵御内疚。所以，你知道，我们可以谈谈个人对此可能有何感受。但我会谈论的，而不是个人的内疚或羞耻，是一个集体挽回面子的工程。而羞耻，在那种意义上，确实如此。所以你输掉了战争，你蒙受了耻辱。你输掉了战斗，你输掉了你为之奋斗的命题。所以在那一点上，在加倍努力上的认知投入变得，如果说有什么的话，
think they feel guilty? No, I think you're absolutely right. I think that they feel self-justified and what they did was they doubled down in their own personal psychological self-justification and rationalization of what they had done. But they did that to ward off shame. They did it to ward off guilt. So we could talk about how individuals may have felt about it. But they did that to ward off shame. They did it to ward off guilt. So, you know, we could talk about how individuals may have felt about it. But what I would talk about, rather than individual guilt or shame, is a collective project of saving face. And shame, in that sense, very much so. So you've lost the war, you're disgraced. You've lost the fight and you've lost the proposition that you fought to uphold. And so at that point, the cognitive investment in doubling down becomes, if anything,
增加了。你必须走得更远，以证明你所做的一切都是正确的，你所做的一切都是极好的。羞耻是关于军事失败的。它不是关于事实的。没有感觉——不，他们不认为他们错了。他们不认为他们错了。完全正确。不，不，不，不。他们羞耻是关于军事失败的。它不是关于那个的。没有感觉。他们不认为他们错了。他们不认为他们错了。完全正确。不，不，不，不。他们是白人至上主义者。
increased. And you have to go that much further to prove that everything that you did was right and everything you did was fabulous. The shame is about military defeat. It's not about facts. There's no sense- No, they don't think they were wrong. They don't think they were wrong. Exactly. No, no, no, no. They shame is about military defeat. It's not about that. There's no sense. They don't think they were wrong. They don't think they were wrong. Exactly. No, no, no, no. They're white supremacists.
他们是顽固的白人至上主义者。所以玛格丽特·米切尔，例如，如果玛格丽特·米切尔在这个播客上，她会说奴隶制没有错。她会吗？或者她会怎么说？到了1930年代，在70年内，他们认为奴隶制是错的吗？
They're intransigent white supremacists. So Margaret Mitchell, for example, if Margaret Mitchell was on this podcast, she would say that slavery wasn't wrong. Would she? Or how would she say? By the 1930s, within 70 years, do they think slavery is wrong?
他们非常努力地不去想它。他们承认也许有些奴隶制是坏的，但他们试图逐案处理。他们试图说，嗯，有些奴隶主很刻薄，我猜，但也有其他人很可爱，而且有快乐的奴隶。所以我在书中试图说的关键点之一是，所有这些都掩盖了奴隶制本身就是终极虐待的事实。而关于某些奴隶主是否比其他人更仁慈的问题，如果你被奴役到很大程度，那是毫无意义的，对吧？所以，我的意思是，读这本书时真正打动我的一件事是
They try really hard not to think about it. They recognize that maybe some slavery was bad, but they try to do it on a case-by-case basis. And they try to say, well, some slave owners were mean, I guess, but there were others who were lovely and there were slaves who were happy. And so one of the key things that I try to say in the book is all of that works to gloss over the fact that enslavement itself is the ultimate mistreatment. And the question of whether some enslavers were kinder than others is moot if you're enslaved to a great degree, right? So, I mean, one of the things that really struck me reading the book was the way in which
使用罪犯和链条帮基本上重新引入了一种奴隶制。我假设如果你是一个白人至上主义者，这样做的理由是你认为黑人是低等的。因此，他们很可能是罪犯。因此，对所有人来说最安全的事情就是把他们锁在链子里，让他们再次在棉花田里工作。嗯，我的意思是，这就是链条帮发生的事情吗？因为它是，我的意思是令人难以置信的统计数据，有链条帮，整个监狱人口中只有四个人是白人什么的，我的意思是惊人的数字。是的，不，它是惊人的，有几件事要记住，这里要回到选举权。所以他们，所以是的，你是对的，汤姆，就
the use of convicts and chain gangs basically reintroduces a form of slavery. And I assume that if you're a white supremacist, the justification for this is you're saying that black people are inferior. Therefore, they are likely to be criminal. And therefore, the safest thing for all concerned is to just lock them up in chains and make them work in cotton fields again uh i mean is that basically what's happening with that because it is i mean incredible statistics that there are chain gangs in which kind of the entire prison population only four people are white or something i mean amazing figures yeah no it's it is amazing and a couple of things to to remember here it goes back to the franchise so what they so yes you're right tom in terms of
态度而言，就像，嗯，无论如何，他们在链条帮里更好。他们更好——因为这就是他们关于奴隶制所说的，不是吗？他们作为奴隶更好。是的，他们应该被奴役，因为他们是野蛮人，对吧？这就是种族主义的来源。这就是白人至上主义运作的方式
the attitudes like well they're better better off in chain gangs anyway. They're better off- Because that's what they're saying about slavery, isn't it? They're better off being slaves. Yeah, they should be enslaved because they're savages, right? That's where the racism comes in. That's how the white supremacism works
是他们不能，他们不适合被放出来，或者他们的孩子，对吧？所以你有良性的家长式版本，也就是他们的孩子，他们需要白人的家长式照顾。这就是你在《乱世佳人》和“妈咪”中得到的那个。完全正确。或者你得到的是他们是不能被信任的野蛮人，他们有，他们理应被奴役，他们需要被远离文明人。
is that they can't, they're not fit to be let loose or their children, right? So you've got the benign paternalistic version, which is their children and they need white paternalistic care. Which is the one you get in Gone with the Wind and Mammy. Exactly. Or you get that they're savages who can't be trusted and they have and they deserve to be enslaved and they need to be kept from civilized people.
对。所以如果选举权在这里真的很重要。对。在这里，对吧？所以发生的事情是，第14修正案说，是一项民权修正案，说人们不能基于种族、肤色或以前的奴役状况受到歧视。他们规定了那三件事，但他们没有规定成千上万的其他你可以歧视人们的原因，以及你因此可以剥夺他们选举权的原因。所以他们做的第一件事就是通过重罪犯剥夺选举权法。所以他们说，如果你是重罪犯，你就不能投票。当然，许多这样的法律仍然存在，并且在深南地区尤其具有争议，但不仅如此，再次，不仅在深南地区。然后你做什么，你制造借口把黑人关起来，这样你就可以让他们
Right. So if the franchise is really important here. Right. here, right? So what happened was, the 14th Amendment says, is a civil rights amendment that says that people cannot be discriminated against on the basis of race, color, or previous condition of servitude. They stipulate those three things, but they don't stipulate thousands of other reasons why you could in fact discriminate against people and why you could therefore remove the franchise from them. And so one of the first things that they did was pass felon disenfranchisement laws. So they said, if you're a felon, you can't vote. And of course, many of those laws still exist and are still very controversial across the deep South in particular, but not only, again, not only in the deep South. And then what you do, you create pretext to lock Black people up so that you can make
成为重罪犯。所以他们要么回到了你喜欢的链条中，或者如果他们被释放，那么他们无论如何都不能投票，你已经有效地剥夺了他们的权力，对吧？关于链条帮要记住的另一个关键点不仅是当时的黑人监狱人口压倒性地是黑人，就像今天依然如此。而且再次，这些是我在书中建立的联系，因为我认为它们非常重要。但当时在深南地区建造的许多联邦监狱
them felons. So they're either back in chains where you like them, or if they get released, then they can't vote anyway, and you've effectively disempowered them, right? And the other key thing to remember about the chain gangs is not just that the Black prison population was so overwhelmingly Black then as it is again to this day. And again, those are connections that I draw in the book because I think they're incredibly important. But that many of the federal prisons that were built at this time in the Deep South
在物理上是建立在旧的奴隶种植园上的。所以他们实际上是把黑人放回了同一个农场，为同一个人采摘同样的棉花，只是现在它是联邦监狱。直到今天，佛罗里达州、密西西比州、路易斯安那州的州立监狱在当地仍然以它们旧的奴隶种植园名字命名。所以帕奇曼是密西西比州立监狱，因为它就是旧的帕奇曼种植园。而路易斯安那州的安哥拉，那是那里的联邦监狱，
were built physically on old slave plantations. So they were literally putting Black people back on the same farms to pick the same cotton for the same people, only now it's a federal prison. And to this day, the state penitentiaries in Florida, in Mississippi, in Louisiana are still known by their old slave plantation names locally. So Parchman is the Mississippi state penitentiary because it was the old Parchman plantation. And Angola in Louisiana, which is the federal penitentiary there,
它很出名，因为它是一个死囚监狱，在当地被称为“农场”。你被送到了农场，对吧？所以，而且他们，因为它建立在一个旧的种植园上。所以他们不仅在理论上复制了它，他们在实践中也复制了它。让我问你关于种植园的问题，因为显然《乱世佳人》不仅仅是一部关于女人的电影。
which is notorious because it's a death row prison, it's known locally just as the farm. You've been sent down to the farm, right? So, and they, because it's built on an old plantation. So they didn't just replicate it in theory, they replicated it in practice. Let me ask you about the plantations, because obviously Gone with the Wind is not just a film about a woman.
它是一部关于一个地方的电影。她痴迷于回到塔拉。她痴迷于重建它。我想汤姆和我去过南方种植园。你去过南方种植园吗？是的，我去过博福特外面的一个。是的，我去过南卡罗来纳州一个叫布恩霍尔的地方，因为其他目的做另一个播客，几年前我下载了
It's a film about a place. She's obsessed with getting back to Tara. She's obsessed with rebuilding it. I think Tom and I have both been to Southern Plantations. Have you been to Southern Plantations? Yeah, I went to one outside Beaufort. Yeah, I went to one in South buford yeah i went to one in um south carolina called boone hall very famous for other purposes doing a different podcast a couple years ago i downloaded
他们的婚礼手册，并且在思考在这个种植园的遗址上结婚会是什么样子，成千上万的人在那里作为奴隶生活和死亡。所以你对那种，你认为《乱世佳人》显然将种植园奉为这种消失的美丽之地，这种文明，你知道，迷失在时间的风中。你认为那个时代已经死了，现在大多数美国人对种植园有非常不同的看法吗？还是你认为那个神话太根深蒂固，永远无法被驱逐？嗯，我认为它可以被驱逐，但我认为它还没有被驱逐。而且我认为我们看到的是这种非凡的认知失调，人们可以在脑海中同时持有这两个完全矛盾的想法而不去思考它们。所以他们可以很容易地说，是的，奴隶制是错的。奴隶制是坏的。
their wedding brochure and was and was thinking about what it would be like to get married on the site of this plantation where thousands of people lived and died as slaves so what's your take on the sort of do you think gone with i think Gone with the Wind clearly enshrines the plantation as this place of kind of vanished beauty, this civilization, you know, lost in the wind of time. Do you think that era has died and that now most Americans have a very different view of plantations? Or do you think that myth is too deeply entrenched ever to be sort of dislodged? Well, I think it can be dislodged, but I don't think it has been yet. And I think that what we see is this kind of extraordinary cognitive dissonance where people can hold these two completely contradictory ideas in their head at the same time and not think about them. And so they can say very easily, yes, slavery was wrong. Slavery was bad.
然后穿上裙撑，去布恩霍尔结婚，想象那一切都很可爱，对吧？正如你所说，但对于某种类型的想象力，我们会思考那个地方的历史现实。对我来说，我这样说，我知道人们并不总是喜欢这些比较，我认为它们在这种情况下完全成立。对我来说，这就像在达豪集中营结婚。我的意思是，这简直就像浪漫化一个集中营。但神话允许存在这两个独立的版本，人们谈论奴隶制，好像它发生的方式与此不同。而我在写这本书时试图思考很多的一件事是，那种运作方式以及它是如何发生的？而且，而且，而且在我看来，发生的事情之一是，我们使用这些陈词滥调的想法、陈词滥调的语言或陈词滥调的图像，阻止我们思考
And put themselves in hoop skirts and go get married at Boone Hall and imagine that that was all lovely, right? And as you say, but for a certain type of imagination, we would be thinking about the historical realities of that place. And to me, and I say this, and I know people don't always take kindly to these comparisons, I think they completely hold up in this case. To me, it's like getting married at Dachau. I mean, it is literally like romanticizing a concentration camp. But the mythology allows for there to be these two separate versions where people talk about slavery as if it happened in a way that was distinct from this. And one of the things that I tried to think about a lot in writing this is kind of how does that work and how does that happen? And, and, and it seems to me that, that one of the things that happens is that, is that we use these cliched ideas, cliched language or cliched images that stop us from thinking about
它。所以你可以谈论一个理想的奴隶种植园，那是人们一直使用的短语，一个理想的奴隶种植园。而且再次，为了让人们对此感到陌生，我尝试，我把集中营放在那里，然后说，如果你谈论一个理想的集中营会发生什么？这太疯狂了。这在道德上是扭曲的。然而人们仍然会谈论一个理想的奴隶种植园，他们会说，嗯，这对非裔美国人来说很糟糕。是的，我承认这一点。好吧，也许。这就像，不，你有一个完整的，这个神话的存在是为了坚持认为它毕竟没有那么糟糕。所以一旦你走了那条路，你接下来怎么处理《乱世佳人》？
it. So you can talk about an ideal slave plantation, and that's a phrase that people use all the time, an ideal slave plantation. And again, to estrange people from that, I try to, I put concentration camp there and go, what would happen if you talked about an ideal concentration camp? It's insane. It's morally deranged. And yet people will still talk about an ideal slave plantation and they'll be like, well, it was bad for African-Americans. Yeah, I grant that. Okay, maybe. And it's like, no, you've got a complete, this mythology was there to insist that it really wasn't that bad after all. So once you've gone down that road, what do you then do with Gone with the Wind?
因为，你知道，这里有一部电影，它嵌入了那个想法，把斯嘉丽·奥哈拉变成了受害者，她的家人是受害者。我现在说，看《乱世佳人》而不畏缩是很难的。我的意思是，你可以是你能想象到的最不“觉醒”的人，你仍然会看那部电影，并发现一些会让你畏缩和退缩的部分，只是想，哦，天哪。而且它比小说少得多种族主义。我可以引用马丁·达灵顿的话吗？
Because, you know, here you've got a film that embeds that idea that turns Scarlett O'Hara into a victim and her family are their victims. It's hard to watch Gone with the Wind now, I would say, without wincing. I mean, you can be the most unwoke person imaginable and you will still watch that film and find bits that will make you wince and cringe and just think, oh my God. And it's a lot less racist than the novel. Could I just quote Martin Darlington?
马丁·达灵顿在推特上说。我不喜欢对一个逝去时代的相当明显的怀旧。为什么它仍然是史上最佳电影名单中的常客？它是邦联宣传。它是邦联宣传。100%正确。所以那个问题中隐含着，你知道，它仍然是……它是经典好莱坞电影制作的胜利。它是经典好莱坞电影制作的胜利。我的意思是，因为萨拉说它是……的一部分。嗯，
Martin Darlington on Twitter. I didn't like the pretty blatant nostalgia for A Bike on Age. Why is it still a regular in best film ever made lists? It's Confederate propaganda. It is Confederate propaganda. 100% right. So implicit in that question, you know, it is still... It's a triumph of classic Hollywood filmmaking. It's a triumph of classic Hollywood filmmaking. I mean, because Sarah said it's part of... Well,
它有点像那种幻想的渴望，不是吗？大萧条，你知道，所以《绿野仙踪》和所有那些东西，我的意思是，它不像一部伟大的电影，甚至是一部更有种族主义色彩的电影《一个国家的诞生》，那是一项巨大的技术成就。是的，所以这些是好莱坞历史上，因此也是世界历史上的图腾电影。某种程度上，你拿它们怎么办？嗯，这就是问题所在，不是吗？嗯，这就是问题所在，对吧？所以，有些人会说我们必须做的是停止观看它们，停止阅读
it's kind of bred of that yearning of fantasy isn't it that the the great depression you know so the wizard of odd and all that kind of stuff i mean it's not as great a film as as an arguably an even more racist film birth of a nation which is a colossal technical achievement yes so so these are these are totemic films in in the history of hollywood and therefore of world. Kind of, what do you do with them? Well, that's the question, isn't it? Well, that's the question, right? So, and some people will say what we have to do is stop watching them and stop reading
它们，停止谈论它们。有些人非常有力地提出了这个观点，并会不同意我把它带回谈话中，并说，这是我认为我们需要思考的事情。我的意思是，你知道，这是一个关于我们如何处理我们自己历史中这些有问题的故事，以及我们对此做什么的持续问题。我的观点是，我宁愿面对它们，拆解它们，并思考它们存在的目的。因为如果我们只是试图把它们放在一边，那么我们发现的是，人们仍然只是从它们那里拿走
them and stop talking about them. And there are people who've made that case very forcefully and would disagree with my bringing it back into the conversation and saying, this is something that I think we need to think about. I mean, you know, it's an ongoing question of how do we handle these problematic stories from our own histories and what do we do about them? My view is I'd rather confront them, dismantle them and think about what they're there for. And because if we just try to put them to one side, then what we've discovered is that people still just take what
他们想要的，除非你真的认为我们应该审查它们，我不相信。而且我不认为在这个谈话中的任何人相信。所以因为我，我在书的早期使用的例子之一是，在2021年的叛乱中，有些人说《乱世佳人》是他们最喜欢的书，对吧？所以你有仍然会读这个故事并遇到它的人。如果你在没有任何反击的情况下这样做，再次，除非你要试图摧毁它，祝你好运，对吧？那不会发生。所以鉴于它在那里，人们正在遇到它，我认为我们能做的最好的事情就是尝试尽可能地将其问题化，并确保人们受过教育，了解它的含义以及它的目的。
they want from them, unless you actually think that we should censor them, which I don't believe. And I don't think anybody, you know, in this conversation believes. So because I, one of the examples that I use fairly early on in the book is that there were some people present at the insurrection in 2021, saying that Gone with the Wind was their favorite book, right? So you've got people who are still going to read this story and encounter it. And if you do it without any kind of pushback, again, unless you're going to try to destroy it, which good luck with that, right? That's not going to happen. So given that it's out there and that people are encountering it, I think that the best thing that we can do is try to problematize it as much as we can and to make sure that people are educated about what it means and what it's
他们想要什么，除非你真的认为我们应该审查他们，我不这么认为。我也不认为参与这次对话的任何人会这么认为。所以我书里很早就用过的一个例子是，2021年暴乱现场有一些人说《飘》是他们最喜欢的书，对吧？所以你仍然会有读到这个故事并接触到它的人。如果你在没有任何反驳的情况下这样做，再说一次，除非你试图摧毁它，祝你好运，对吧？那是不可能发生的。所以既然它已经存在，而且人们正在接触它，我认为我们能做的最好的事情就是尽可能地去质疑它，并确保人们了解它的含义以及它所代表的意义
saying. But also for me, it's to recognize that it captures all kinds of important truths about how we got where we are. And if we deny it in the sense of saying, well, it's actually a very scarlet thing to do is, I'll think about that tomorrow. I don't want to think about that right now. It's a troublesome thought. Well, it is a troublesome thought, but the problem is that it captures a historical reality. The myth is itself a historical reality, right? The mythology happened and it changed political reality in all kinds of ways in the United States. And that has consequences now, regardless of whether we know about it or understand it. And so for me, understanding this mythology helps things like the storming of the Capitol in 2021 make sense.
但对我来说，这也是为了认识到它捕捉到了关于我们如何走到今天这一步的各种重要真相。如果我们否认它，就像是在说，好吧，这其实是一件非常斯嘉丽式的事情，我明天再想吧。我现在不想考虑这个问题。这是一个令人困扰的想法。嗯，它确实是一个令人困扰的想法，但问题在于它捕捉到了一种历史现实。神话本身就是一种历史现实，对吧？神话确实发生了，并且以各种方式改变了美国的政治现实。无论我们是否了解或理解它，这在现在都会产生后果。因此，对我来说，理解这种神话有助于让像2021年国会大厦骚乱这样的事情变得可以理解。
And that's kind of one of the key arguments I make in the book is that if you understand this stuff, then at least you can understand where we are and it starts to become intelligible. And so I do it on the basis of know your enemy. I mean, we have to know what it is that we're combating in order to combat it, it seems to me. And this is a kind of, although Gone with the in your view that has had such a bail I mean you clearly think it's had a really baleful effect on American culture politics I mean is it the worst in your view because it was so successful and because it's so deeply enshrined the idea of the lost cause um I should say I was two things in answer that one is that because I haven't said this yet and it's important and since Tom said know, you barely saw it and barely remember it. I,
这也是我在书中提出的关键论点之一，即如果你理解了这些东西，那么至少你可以理解我们所处的境地，它开始变得清晰起来。所以我这样做是基于“知己知彼”的原则。我的意思是，我们必须知道我们在对抗什么，才能去对抗它，在我看来是这样。虽然《乱世佳人》在你看来产生了一种如此……我的意思是，你显然认为它对美国文化政治产生了非常有害的影响。我的意思是，在你看来它是最糟糕的吗？因为它如此成功，因为它如此深刻地确立了“迷途事业”的理念？嗯，我应该说，回答这个问题有两点。第一点是，因为我还没说过，这很重要，而且既然汤姆说他几乎没看过，也几乎不记得了，我……
I need to say for listeners that, you know, I grew up watching this movie and reading this book and I loved the movie. I mean, I loved it. So I'm very much an apostate here. And it's important to understand that because I also understand the feelings of those who love it, but I have come to believe that it had a baleful influence on my society.
我需要告诉听众，你知道，我是看着这部电影、读着这本书长大的，我非常喜欢这部电影。我的意思是，我真的很喜欢它。所以我在这里算是一个背离者。理解这一点很重要，因为我也理解那些喜欢它的人的感受，但我已经开始相信，它对我的社会产生了有害的影响。
Absolutely. The baleful influence is because you love it. I mean, that's it's because I mean, it's because it's- It's because it's effective. Yeah, it's effective and powerful. And Scott Carr is an amazing character and it's great, yeah. And so, but then it, yeah,
绝对是这样。这种有害的影响正是因为你喜欢它。我的意思是，这是因为……我的意思是，这是因为它……是因为它很有效。是的，它既有效又强大。斯嘉丽·奥哈拉是一个了不起的角色，这很棒，是的。所以，但是后来，是的，
and it convinces you to think all kinds of things that on second thought, I don't think I want to think. And that's the process of what I'm trying to take people through with the book. But to answer Dom's question directly, no, I think Birth of a Nation was probably worse. And the reason I say that is because it directly inspired the rebirth of the Klan in 1915. And we know that. There's all kinds of ways in which that's documented. And so it led directly to the torture and murder of thousands of African Americans in the early decades of the 20th
它会说服你去想各种各样的事情，事后想想，我不认为我想去想这些。这就是我试图通过这本书引导人们经历的过程。但要直接回答多姆的问题，不，我认为《一个国家的诞生》可能更糟糕。我之所以这么说，是因为它直接促成了1915年三K党的复兴。我们知道这一点。这在各方面都有记录。因此，它直接导致了20世纪头几十年成千上万名非裔美国人遭受酷刑和谋杀。
century. It's not clear to me that the Gone with the Wind has documented the same direct murderous outcome that Birth of a Nation had. And, you know, Birth of a Nation affected politics in a more, and I'm going to use this word, unreconstructed kind of a way where Gone with the Wind was challenged from the moment that it came out, partly because of Birth of a Nation. So African Americans were pushing back against Gone with the Wind from the second that it emerged. So it never had such an unproblematic effect on the culture as Birth of a Nation was allowed to have for several decades when it enjoyed this kind of sway over white culture. So I think that was even worse.
世纪。我不确定《乱世佳人》是否记录了与《一个国家的诞生》相同的直接杀戮后果。而且，你知道，《一个国家的诞生》以一种更……我要用这个词，更“未被改造”的方式影响了政治，而《乱世佳人》从它问世的那一刻起就受到了挑战，部分原因就是《一个国家的诞生》。所以非裔美国人从《乱世佳人》出现的那一秒起就开始抵制它。因此，它从未像《一个国家的诞生》那样在几十年里对白人文化拥有那种影响力，从而对文化产生如此无争议的影响。所以我认为那部电影更糟糕。
But that's a race to the bottom, as we might say. And certainly not to excuse Gone with the Wind. Well, Sarah, thanks so much. That was a brilliant exposition. And I hope you have all enjoyed what's five episodes now we've done on the American Civil War, incredibly complex and important. The question is whether this podcast will send people rushing to watch Gone With the Wind
但这就像是“比烂”，正如我们所说的那样。当然，这并不是要为《乱世佳人》开脱。好吧，莎拉，非常感谢。那是一次精彩的阐述。我希望大家都喜欢我们这五集关于美国内战的内容，这非常复杂且重要。问题是，这个播客是否会让人冲去观看《乱世佳人》
and what Sarah would think about that. I guess you wouldn't be unhappy, would you, if people were watching Gone With the Wind on the back of this podcast? I mean, I'll be honest with you and say I'd rather they were reading my book. Or unless, I mean, all facetiousness aside, if they are, I would hope that they would read my book too and to understand the way that they're in dialogue.
以及莎拉对此会有什么看法。我想如果人们在听了这个播客后去观看《乱世佳人》，你不会不高兴吧？我的意思是，我会诚实地告诉你，我宁愿他们读我的书。或者，除非……我的意思是，抛开所有玩笑话，如果他们真的去看了，我希望他们也能读读我的书，以理解它们之间是如何对话的。
Okay. So Sarah's book, The Wrath to Come, Gone with the Wind and The Lies America Tells. Thank you so much, Sarah. Thank you all for listening. We will see you soon. Tomorrow's another day. Goodbye. Tomorrow is another day.
好的。那么莎拉的书是《即将到来的愤怒：乱世佳人与美国所说的谎言》。非常感谢你，莎拉。谢谢大家的收听。我们很快会再见。明天又是新的一天。再见。明天又是新的一天。
Bye. Bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest isorypod.com. That's just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，即 restishistorypod.com。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。即 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。